[Music]
welcome everybody to Long Prime daily
I'm Jesse Weber parents of an Idaho
College student brutally stabbed death
in her bed are speaking out about the
investigation as well as a lack of
information from police we have learned
the layout of the home this is where
roommates were sleeping when police
believe the attack happened two of the
University of Idaho students were asleep
on the ground floor of the home when
four people were killed on the second
and third floors police think the attack
happened around 3 or 4 a.m on November
13th since then no suspect has been
identified and no work murder weapon has
been recovered police have said that
they don't believe the other roommates
were at the home were involved in the
killings the University of Idaho
community and surrounding Moscow Idaho
have been on edge especially as
information has been slow to come out
while police said at least one of the
victims was targeted then took that back
then clarified the home or people in it
might have been targeted the parents of
Kaylee Gonzalez say according to an
autopsy report their daughter may have
been killed in a more vicious way than
the other three victims
their means of death don't match
baddies they don't and Kaylee's cause of
death it does not mess based on the
autopsy report they don't match their
points of damage don't match I'm just
gonna say it wasn't leaked to me I
earned that I paid for that funeral sent
my daughter to college to get an
education she came back in the box and I
can speak on that
Kaylee's parents and others also spoke
last week at a vigil held at the
University of Idaho
so then they went to high school
together then they started looking at
colleges they came here together
they eventually get into the same
apartment together
and in the end they died together
in the same room in the same bed I think
all the people working on trying to
figure this out
and uh
it really means a lot
all right I want to bring my co-host
into former trial Attorney Terry Austin
Terry this is incredibly difficult
situation and I understand the desire to
speak out but could these comments maybe
hinder or harm the investigation in any
way yeah Jesse you know there is a
chance that leaked information could
hinder the investigation but there are
pros and cons to sharing leads on the
one hand the police may want to keep
information secret to avoid tipping off
any sort of suspect for example
knowing that the suspect may have
entered from the outside could alert the
suspect that forensic evidence might
include Footprints and guess what the
suspect could dispose of the shoes worn
on the night of the murders on the other
hand there are situations where the more
the public knows the better just imagine
if the entire city of Moscow was given
relevant information they could serve as
the eyes and ears of the police I mean
actually it sounds like these parents
are ready to hire their own investigator
or give an award and frankly who could
blame them it's been three weeks since
the murders and no one wants the case to
grow cold I am sure that the authorities
are doing the best they can but there
was already significant miscommunication
about targeted or not targeted like you
said and frankly the authorities ruled
out a number of suspects and I don't
think they should have done that so
quickly Brian I'm here with my co-host
Brian buckmeyer as well you look at the
difference in the the way they were
killed what does that tell you about
this investigation and the murders yeah
so take the ways that they were killed
as fathers saying that his daughter had
different points of entries and
different means of killing I think he
means different cause of death but if
we're thinking about it just from
stabbing as well as where they are in
the house three floors the two people on
the first floor the entryway they're not
killed but his daughter is at the top of
the house and seems to be killed more
aggressively than even the young lady
next to him that suggested either she or
that room specifically was targeted did
a person in her Circle know her hate her
um to send her hateful messages we don't
know but the method of the killing the
location of the individuals might give
us more clues and I'm hoping that the
police are tracking down those because
these parents need answers yeah I say
this on every show we are going to
continue to follow this until we see a
conclusion because there's so many more
details that are coming out and we
really do want to keep following it
welcome back everybody we have a major
update for you out of Houston in the
shooting death of Migos rapper takeoff
the 28 year old artist was gunned down
in the early hours of November 1st and
took investigators nearly four weeks to
arrest the two men allegedly involved
the Houston Police Department announced
the arrest of 33-year-old Patrick Xavier
Clark on Friday Also rested was
23-year-old Cameron Joshua who faces a
charge of unlawful carrying of a weapon
during the news the press conference I
should say Sergeant Michael burrow from
Houston's homicide division provided
more details on the circumstances around
takeoff's death and the holes they still
need to fill in the investigation
but I can't tell you uh to confirm some
of the speculations out there the event
was a private party
there was a lucrative dice game that
went on at the event there was an
argument that happened afterwards
outside the bowling alley which led to
the shooting I can tell you that takeoff
was not involved in playing in the dice
game he was not involved in the argument
that happened outside he was not armed
he was an innocent bystander
some important case factors you know the
chief was uh
was mentioning some of the the timing
here I mean
we've boiled it down to over 30 people
that were standing outside we have an
exact number we're not going to put that
out when the shooting happened
literally every single one of those
people left the scene without giving a
statement to police we found some a few
of them that night we found others since
then but it's important that those
people come forward and we're still
looking to talk to a lot of those people
and we will be looking to find you it
will be easier if you come find us it'll
be easier for you it'll be easier for us
as well
Brian over to you you've been following
the investigation very closely can you
give us some insight into what might
have led to takeoff's death well Jesse
the investigation is still ongoing but
according to police it looks like
takeoff was an innocent bystanders we
heard right there in the report think
about it lucrative dice game he's not
involved there's an argument that to me
suggests that this was something
collateral that takeoff may have just
been an innocent bystanders as they said
either walking by or just a part of the
party now the question becomes
um what more are the police going to
find in order to connect this shooter to
the death of takeoff police are saying
that they have video evidence of Clark
shooting a gun outside the bowling alley
we'll take all those killed and a
close-up of him holding a gun Morris
probably needed though the prosecution
wants to prove this case Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt forensic eyewitness
accounts and video are going to make or
break this case if they just have him
shooting a gun on camera in the camera
not showing takeoff die or getting hit
by the bullet I'd expect them to be able
to match the bullet to the gun that
Clark shot someone's probably going to
have to ID him as a shooter or they're
having some sort of video that's why
they're asking for that but of course
we'll see how this case continues well
Terry it seems they need more
information right authorities are asking
people to come forward what happens if
they don't well you know it's
interesting he said it would be a lot
easier for us if you come forward but he
also said it'll be a lot easier for you
if you come forward obviously people
coming forward can give information it
sounds like everyone just scattered
after the shooting occurred and they
said that they know it's over 30 they
don't want to say the exact number to me
that means they looked at that street
camera and they determined exactly how
many people were out there and they may
even at this point have some of the
names based on the few information that
they do have from the people they've
spoken to so I think they will
ultimately talk to everyone and people
are probably afraid that they're going
to get implicated so they don't want to
come forward so I think that's why
what's going on but one way or another
the police is going to find them and
they are going to question them yeah you
would think a shooting like this in such
a public place would be a simple case
but it's been anything but that really
complicated Brian Terry thank you so
much everyone out there thanks so much
for joining us here on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]